we're at where we left off is that we
blew your minds open with this very tiny
little idea namely the what was the
object we talked about last night
the inner circle right so I've drawn
better actually
anyway um it's easier to draw a big
circle cities or small circles okay ugly
are you ready
great we introduced this guy and we said
look you can think of trigonometry not
just as ratios of sides in a right angle
triangle but as functions of an angle
any angle you like it doesn't matter
whether it can fit in a triangle let
alone a right angle triangle or not so
now this idea of sine theta cos theta
tan theta means we don't have to think
of it we'd have to draw a picture of a
triangle anymore we can just take
different angles any angles we like and
just see what happens in fact when we
were having a go we went from naught to
ninety two angles that don't belong
anywhere in a triangle 180 270
I didn't bring things back all the way
around because this is the wonderful
thing about the unit circle all circles
in fact this spot over here right if
there's an angle that goes with that
there's an angle that goes with that
what would you estimate just come up
with a number
reasonably sort of according to the
scale what does it look like it would be
ya then 45 is a great idea 45 okay now
that sure does look like 45 except 45 is
not the only angle it could be for
instance if I start from where do I stop
from again it's the positive x-axis
right and I start going around
anti-clockwise I could sure enough just
go up like that and there's my 45
degrees but there's another way excuse
me there's another way I can get to that
same spot I could keep going around and
do a full extra revolution if I so chose
okay now if I went all the way
around and then did the 45 what would
that angle be 405 degrees 405 degrees
now because I end up on the same spot
I should predict that I get the same
value have your calculator there right
if you haven't gotten out yet do that
I picked 45 because it is one of those
three values which I introduced last
time as a nice value it plays nicely
excuse me
it plays nicely with our trig functions
it gives us a number that's quite easy
to write now I'm going to teach you a
bit of a trick right now you can't
remember and I hope you do get to the
point where you remember what this exact
value is but you're probably not there
yet so I want you to go ahead put sign
45-minute calculator when you hit equals
what do you get dot dot dot dot dot okay
now in time like I said your memory will
start to you know assimilate these ideas
and you'll know actually what exact
value that is without all the decimal
rubbish but at the moment you don't so
I'm going to teach you this little trick
while this is still in your display I
would like you to keep the answer
squared button can you do that can you
square it okay now when you square it
you should get a nice number right in
fact if I recall you should get 1/2 is
that correct 0.5 okay now what this
tells you is and pick up your pencil
again or pen and go back to your book
what this tells you is that if you
squared the right-hand side well that
means you've also squared the left-hand
side do you agree this is not sine 45
anymore this is sine 45 square agreed
but this tells you what the exact value
is it's kind of like a sneaky way of
getting at it if you see something like
x squared equals 9 what's X there are
two possible values possible minus 3 in
this case I can actually eliminate one
of those values watch if I take the
square root I'm trying to undo what I
just did I squared
and now I'm doing the square that's a
bad cue the square root I go back to
sine 45 on the left hand side but unlike
here what I had to say oh it might be
this one it might be that one it could
be plus or minus
you actually know from the first line
you wrote down which answer it is is it
the plus or is it the - it has to be the
plus because that's what the calculator
told you in the first place
so if you take the square root of this
guy the square root of 1/2 you can also
write that as 1 on the square root of 2
because the square root of 1 is after
all 1 so this isn't exact value we've
learnt this last time do you remember we
drew the isosceles triangle and it came
out ok so I was suggesting that if we
have a go at another angle that's close
to the Reds this 405 degrees if we go
all the way which way am i rotating this
way this way around then go ahead punch
it into your calculator sine 405 because
it is 360 degrees later
you should find it's equal to zero point
seven oh seven zero right now on that
basis you should be able to predict to
me a couple of other angles in fact an
infinite number of angles that will all
be equal to the same thing can you give
me another example any angle you like
that should give you the same thing any
takers okay if you add 360 again that's
I'm not going to draw it cuz I look
ridiculous but if I go around another
360 I should land on the same spot and
every time I go 360 so I guess what did
we just say 765 all the same okay now
that's all cool that's great I'm gonna
come back to this idea of how far you
can keep on going with sign in a second
but there's one more point that I'm a
bit more interested in I need another
color and if you've got another color
there you should use it too okay we said
sign cause 10 they're not about ratios
anymore we defined them
new ways as coordinates sine-theta which
corner isn't of this point it's the
y-coordinate what about cause it's the
x-coordinate and ten is not either of
the coordinates it's actually yeah it's
Y on X which is sine over cos okay now I
want you to look carefully at the
diagram if sine theta really is the
y-coordinate then you can see there's
another spot on the circle which has the
same y-coordinate as up here
it's got the same sign as that point up
there hmm
figure this for a second the
y-coordinate is 102 that's what your
calculator helped us work out okay
so therefore this coordinate is
something as the x-coordinate and one on
root 2 that's the y-coordinate that's
sine look the other spot on the circle
which has the same y-coordinate is the
same up and down position right can you
see where it is do you see where it's
hiding isn't it oh yeah think about it
think about what like wouldn't its mean
y-coordinates mean how far up and down
you are okay well if this guy is one on
route to that high then isn't that isn't
there going to be a spot on the opposite
side of the circle where it has to be
because circles are always symmetrical
right in fact they're symmetrical every
possible way okay now think if it's
literally on the other side engage your
brain new color sorry what is this angle
going to be
ah okay so if it really is a reflection
right if it really is a reflection see
how this is 45 on this side well it
should be 45 on this side as well
wouldn't you agree
those are both supposed to be 45 I just
flipped it across yeah you see you see
so therefore all the way across is 180
but I didn't go that far I only went to
this far right so I'm short by 45
degrees so this angle in here is a
hundred and eighty takeaway 45 degrees
last I checked that is 135 go reach for
your calculator sine of 135 and lo and
behold it's the same the other it needs
your calculator to confirm this stuff
for you you can see what's going on okay
and what I want us to do is to put this
all together can you draw for me a set
of axes but in a little bit of an
unusual way we're only going to draw the
right-hand side of this set of axes and
it's gonna be really really long okay